the Joe Rogan experience there was this
thing about these Texas kids and they
were they were piled onto this this area
together it's like this I don't know it
looks like some outdoor party area but
they were just stacked in there like
sardines and people like holy [ __ ] like
yeah yeah you you didn't you didn't
raise your kids right you did even if
you did if you they're hanging around
with other kids they're fuck-ups they're
gonna [ __ ] up
we all did that I was involved in a lot
of really stupid [ __ ] because I was
around some kids that were sketchy when
I was a kid you know especially when I
lived in Jamaica Plain Jamaica Plain was
like this this area that we only lived
there for about maybe less than two
years it was like a year and a half and
it was like an urban section of Boston
that since been gentrified apparently
apparently it's nice now but back then
it was sketchy it was like all kinds of
like everyone Irish kids Italian kids
black kids Puerto Rican kids but no one
was getting good parenting everyone's
parents smoked people were drunk like
their chaos people they were like it was
weird there were wild people like the
whole block was filled with wild people
they weren't bad people there wasn't
like a crime infested dangerous
neighborhood who was sketchy and
everyone was a mess everyone on my block
my next-door neighbor we've talked about
this before they were a punk rock band
called death in the shopping mall and
they used to play downstairs in the
basement and so they have these thick
layers of carpet set up in the basement
so they had carpet all over the door
carpet all over the ceiling many many
many many many layers and these guys
would [ __ ] and go off and they're
playing guitar and [ __ ] screaming and
I was I guess I was 11 no 13 yeah I was
13 years old because it was middle it
was middle school right before I went to
high school so I was 13 years old and I
was like fascinated because I was just
becoming a teenager and living next door
to these [ __ ] savages these savages
they just were playing crazy [ __ ]
loud music and you didn't see punk rock
people a lot back then I remember where
there's a kid at the bus stop on
mabry and he had a punk rock haircut
every morning guard around the school
head we'll look at him he's a mohawk his
mom let him have a mohawk well I went
from San Francisco to Gainesville
Florida which was a college town nor did
Gainesville
yeah I was in Gainesville Florida when I
was 11 to 13 you and River Phoenix so we
lived there for a little bit and that
was like just kind of college people and
in the apartments we lived in just
regular folks
it was nothing crazy you didn't really
see too much craziness involved as far
as crime or sketchy folks everyone was
pretty normal
different races different backgrounds
but you know just people apartment life
you know yeah but then we moved to
Boston man those kids were wild they'd
break into [ __ ] warehouse buildings
and they were in this day everyone knew
how to steal a car they were like 13
they were all smoking everyone was
smoking like I immediately went into
this crazy environment of whoa whoa whoa
whoa I was like my dog Marshall and like
a roomful of like rabid German Shepherds
I was like hey guys can we talk this out
I'm from an apartment complex I'm not
used to like semi-urban kids
that's an interesting transition as a
young child it was rough man
it was rough when I was 10 I moved to a
neighborhood where was very aggressive
we're in route at same same sort of
situation yeah we we lived in it we
lived in a real white-trash neighborhood
but my dad kind of sheltered me a little
bit and and then I moved in with like
and there was all boys like they're all
like a little older than me and I
remember I learned the word [ __ ] real
quick the first thing I learned that and
how to hold an ice cube in my [ __ ]
really important things to have I
remember coming home and being like to
my sister a [ __ ] yeah you can you can
certainly get ruined by bad kids and no
one knows that more than dads like dad
see you hanging around with sketchy kids
I get hey I don't like you hanging
around with that [ __ ] guy like dad
see where that stuff goes cuz sketchy
boys commit murder you know I'm saying
like a sketchy boys joined gangs
boys Rob cars and kill people drunk
driving and set fires to warehouses
that's what sketchy boys do
sketchy boys can get you locked up like
we did a lot of sketchy [ __ ] when I was
13 years old and I remember thinking
like wow these guys have been doing this
their whole life and they're 13 I mean
well I just sort of stumbled I just want
to be someone's friend
you know in my [ __ ] is that that's
when I took up fishing I really got into
fish [ __ ] away from these kids I didn't
have I didn't have your brain I kind of
just picked up with them every time man
I did not feel protected when I was
young and it's one of the reasons why I
value community today when I was young I
felt like really disconnected my parents
split up and then my mom moved in with
my stepdad and he's a great guy and
everything like that and we but we moved
around a lot so I was never around kids
that I knew for any long period of time
and I never felt like I was safe because
I remember like kids would always start
fights like boys if you move in a new
neighborhood boys always want to start
fights especially if girls think you're
cute you're cute boys want to [ __ ] you
up I mean and then when I was 13 I was
like I just gotta get the [ __ ] away from
these kids and I found this lake that
was near me I really got into fishing it
was called that Jamaica pond and Jamaica
Plain they would stock it with trout and
there was bass in there all kinds of
fish man you can fish there all that
this whole community of people fish
they're mostly like older folks they
would fish there and but you learn about
fishing I start fished like all the time
and all the time that's you know that
speaks a lot to who you are because
that's not who I am
like was dove in when I remember I
remember being like totally anti-pot and
then my buddy came in is like you wanna
get high and I was like okay I'm in and
we got high on it on Sal's dock well I
had friends like that too there was a
friend named Victor Brown ski I'll never
forget he was the most criminal out of
all of our friends and he was selling
weed when we were 13 dealing with salad
weed at 13 you just call him he had the
weed and he was just like a dude that
like it seen some [ __ ] like even 13 he
wasn't mean or anything like that was a
nice guy he just come home like what's
up man
everything cool you guys cool yeah
season wish I had that [ __ ]
conference
[Applause]